we literally just got the biggest iphone
14 lineup leak that confirms a lot of
the leaks and rumors and speculations
over the past couple of months but
before i show you guys this new photo of
the iphone 14 lineup i want to mention
that a lot of people are already
disappointed they are saying that it's
ugly and they can't believe apple is
doing this but i want to make it clear
that i completely disagree and i think
everybody is wrong but before i get into
that photo i want to refresh you guys of
the renders that i created with renders
by shy lesh and as you can see we have
this dual hole punch cut out and the
current large rear camera bump which is
going to be getting even bigger this
year as you can see these are some
pretty sick
renders but jumping right into this
photo from a source that was leaked on
weibo as you can see we have the
official iphone
14 lineup display
panels now this is a really big deal
because it confirms the exact situation
with the bezels the dual hole punch
cutout the thinner earpiece speaker and
much more but before i dig deep into all
of those details i want to prove to you
guys why i believe this is completely
legit now first of all john prosser from
front page tech was actually the first
one who reported this on youtube but he
says it is ugly and he can't believe
that apple is doing this but once again
i disagree with them and all over the
internet like on the mac rumors post
comments a lot of people are saying this
looks horrible the notch is cleaner i
hate to say it but i like the notch
better and a lot of other people are
disappointed with this design but i
think they are all
wrong and even a lot of people on
twitter are saying that it looks ugly
and even worse than the notch and i
completely disagree and i will explain
why in just a minute but before i get
into all of that i want to confirm why i
think this leak is completely legit well
first of all john prosser confirmed with
shrimp apple pro and he said that yes
this is exactly what we should be
expecting and the reason this is a big
deal is because shrimp apple pro was
actually the first source that leaked
the dual hole punch cutout and he was
correct and he was even vouched for by
mark german and ross young who are the
most reliable analysts currently right
now and the most interesting part is
that he gave us an exclusive leak back
on january 7th saying that the regular
iphone 14 and 14 max models are gonna
have a refined
notch and what he showed right here is
that the notch will now be more rounded
on this inside edge which is exactly
what he was saying and these new display
panel leaks confirm it and the awesome
thing is that shrimp apple pro also
confirmed the leaks of these iphone 14
lineup molds as you can see these molds
show off the differences in the camera
bumps and these bumps are massive and
you can even see that the actual lenses
themselves are wider and larger on the
pro models compared to the max models
and that's a very important detail
because
mixture quo and other sources have
confirmed that the new main camera on
the pro models will be 42 mega pixels
which is why they're getting larger and
now we also got these plastic 3d printed
mock-ups for case manufacturers to base
them off of and they also match up to
all of these leaks including these ones
right here now this is important because
i want to take you back to the iphone 13
lineup leaks yes way back in march of
2021 we got very similar display panel
leaks and in the beginning some people
were doubting them but they ended up
being exactly what we got on the iphone
13 lineup as you can see the smaller
notch with the relocated earpiece
speaker which we got on the iphone 13
lineup and dan roy back in april of last
year he even showed off these new
display panels and of course they were
perfectly legit and this is a big deal
because
it's april right now and those leaks
happened in april so this really matches
up perfectly now as far as these
aluminum printed molds i also think that
they are legit because if you go back to
last year back in july we also had these
dummy models created and leaked and this
is exactly what we got with the iphone
13 model so this was legit as well
and we also got these ones which are
actually aluminum showing off more
detail in terms of the camera bumps and
finally here is the last piece of
evidence for why i think these display
panels are legit yes mark german just
retweeted them saying that this is the
best look yet at the new pro cutout so
he completely agrees that these are
legitimate and now with that said let me
answer the question of why everybody is
wrong about the dual hole punch camera
looking worse than the notch well first
of all greg's gadget made a very good
point when he showed what everybody
thought about the leaked iphone 4 design
as you can see people are saying that it
looks hideous short answer no it looks
horrendous fake ugly no way however
people loved the iphone 4 design after
it actually came out and it was in
people's hands and i think the exact
same thing is gonna happen this time
around in september when they finally
launch people start using them people
start experiencing the screen real
estate difference they're gonna love
that apple made this change to the pro
models and as you can see right here it
shows a huge difference between the
regular iphone 14s and the pro models
first of all you can see a clear
difference in the bezels and you get a
lot of extra screen real estate in this
area so it actually looks very very nice
now if i actually pull up the display
leak itself we can get a close-up of
these differences as you can see the
bezels are now 20
thinner than on the regular 13 and 14
models which are unchanged and if you
look at that earpiece speaker it's now
getting wider and three times slimmer so
it's almost unnoticeable but look at
this entire section of notch which is
now going away you have this extra
screen real estate in between the two
cutouts and above and the really big
point that i want to make clear to you
guys is the only reason we're able to
get thinner bezels reduced by 20
is because apple chose to go with the
dual hole punch design as you can see
the cameras and face id system is
actually moved down
so there's extra space on the inside for
the extra screen up at the top so
because they moved it down you get the
extra screen space and they could not do
that if the notch was still around
because it would get lower and it would
look like the pixel
notch which is absolutely horrible but
moving on to these images you can see a
huge difference in screen real estate i
mean this looks great and this is on the
pro model the smaller one this is not on
the max model and finally this image
probably shows it off the best shared by
shrimp apple pro as you can see look at
all of the extra screen real estate and
i think that's totally worth any people
who are doubting the dual hull punch
design i think it's going to look great
and now if you're still doubting why
apple would make this decision to move
the cameras down and give us the dual
hole punch cutout well we got a pretty
awesome leak from ming cha quo saying
that the front camera of the four new
iphone 14 models is going to have an
upgraded selfie camera with auto focus
and
faster aperture f 1.9 compared to the
fixed focus f 2.2 so we are getting a
better selfie camera this time around
and that is awesome and as far as the
rear camera once again mark german
agrees that we're getting 48 megapixels
on the pro model so apple is really
trying to differentiate the max models
the 14 and the 14 max compared to the
pro and the pro max and really trying to
upsell it and then finally the last
detail i want to share is that the new
color we're getting for the iphone 14
pro is a new darker purple which is
unfortunate because i didn't really like
the sierra blue and i wish we would get
this new bronze because i mean look at
it it looks beautiful but with that said
if you totally disagree with my thoughts
on the new dual hole punch camera
looking great and all those people being
wrong about it then let me know down in
the comment section below but if you
enjoyed the video click the circle above
to subscribe and check out one of those
two right over there thanks for watching
and we'll see you in the next video
[Music]